الشرطه البريطانيه في قفص الاتهام والتهمه
التحيز ضد النساء وفضح خصوصيه الضحايا
قضيه البحث عن المفقوده نيكولا بولي التي
شغلت الراي العام ابرزت وجها ذكوريا
للشرطه
فالكشف ان نيكولا تمر بسن الياس وضعها
بشكل تلقائي في خانه الاضطراب النفسي وهي
حجه عاده ما يستخدمها الذكوريون اما لنبدا
النساء او التقليل من شانهم او نزعي صفه
الضحيه عنهن
نيكولا كانت تسير برفقه كلبها الى جانب
النهر كما تفعل عاده ثم اختفت تعددت
التكهنات واختلفت السيناريوهات المطروحه
حول اختفائها حتى ان الفضول دفع البعض
للتوجه الى بلده لانشر حيث اختفت نيكولا
للسرق معلومه من هنا او هناك وبعد ان طالت
المده اضطرت الشرطه للخروج بتبريرات
فجاءت التصريحات لتصب الزيت على نار
معاناه عائلتها والمقربين منها تاره تقول
الشرطه انها سقطت بالنهر وتاره اخرى تاتي
باعذار عشوائيه فنيكولا لبست بمختلف
التصنيفات واغربها فلسبب او لاخر رات
الشرطه ان مرورا نيكولاب من قطاع الطماط
يعد تفصيلا مهما للكشف عنه
او ان ادمانها على الكحول هو جراء المرور
بما يسمى بسن الياس تسميه تعتبر بذاتها
مجحفه بحق النساء
ودون توجيه اتهامات معينه كانت تصريحات
الشرطه كافيه للتلميح بان وراء اختفاء
نيكولا حاله نفسيه مضطربه تمر بها النساء
بعمرها كما لو ان الضحيه هي الملامه
ضاع الطمط والادمان على الكحول بينيكولا
المختفيه واعتبرته عذرا واهيا يقلل من
جديه التعامل مع حادثه اختفائها
وزيره
الكشف عن حياه نيكولا الشخصيه
عثر على الجثه بعد اسابيع وبقيت التكهنات
حول سبب وفاتها ولكن المؤكد ان قضيه
نيكولا هزت الثقه بالشرطه مره اخرى فمن
قضايا تحرش الى التمييز ضد النساء ملفات
متراكمه تضع الشرطه في صف ثاني احيانا من
لندن لصباح العربيه وعبد الحق